pam's watercolor painting of the dunder
mifflin building is symbolic of the
quirky sentimentality the office of oaks
when she lifts the painting from the
wall and takes it home in the finale it
feels like a definitive goodbye wrapped
up in cozy happy memories however there
was a proposed scene in a season 6
episode in which aaron and kelly would
have accidentally ruined the watercolor
while pam was on her honeymoon
fortunately jenna fisher who plays pam
was having none of it fisher recalled on
the office ladies podcast how she had to
fight to have the proposed scene removed
her concerns were initially shot down at
the table read even though she explained
how much the painting meant to the
series she recalled saying you cannot
destroy pam's painting she went on to
call the painting the heartbeat of the
show and said she told the producers it
couldn't be destroyed for a gag in the
end fisher convinced editor dave rogers
and writer brent forrester to see sense
and they agreed to leave the painting
intact